this is the worst Hunter Hunter review
I've ever read and because I've
experienced it you now need to as well
Hunter Hunter is one of the many
overrated Shonen anime out there and I
can summarize my review with one
sentence if you became kind of
interested in Hunter Hunter because you
have heard it so much more than just a
Shonen don't believe it because it's
exactly that just another Shonen now I'm
not a fan of Shonen and if you read this
review you'll find out why so this anime
is not made for me but just for more
diversity and Views I will analyze the
anime A bit closer so I look forward to
that analysis but let's be fair here
Shonen isn't for everyone and on mass it
has a lot of problems as a genre many of
which can be articulated and reasonably
argued however that is not this review
Hunter Hunter is one of those anime
where you can literally see the quality
dropping with the earlier episodes being
made nicely and at the end it has one of
the longest pacings I have ever seen now
I do think it's fair to say that the
Chimera antar in particular is long it's
very long did it need to be that long
maybe but but also probably not that's
not what This reviewer is getting at
them since the art style isn't in any
form detailed and costly they can't tell
me they ran out of money I assume they
just wanted to milk the cash count to
the end and stretch the manga material
of 20 episodes in relation to the
beginning to around 60 so what we have
Happening Here is the one piece argument
which is very legitimate with that
series the anime adapts less than a
chapter's worth of material per episode
it is stretched out and milks like the
infinite pirate cow it is the reason why
this doesn't work with Hunter Hunter
though is that the Chimera an talk is
yes episodes but that art covers
132 chapters so that's an adaptation
rate of just over two per episode which
is very good pacing if that were one
piece those 132 chapters would turn into
138 episodes so the Chimera an talk is
very Faithfully adapted so this
criticism is misplaced that's to put it
generously to put it bluntly and very
ungenerously the reviewer doesn't know
what they're talking about and from here
on out their opinion should be
disregarded from every sentence onwards
like I said before the start of the show
was quite nice it had a few things which
didn't really make any sense especially
the riddles but it had a nice buildup
and a good pacing it seemed to me as if
the start also really wanted to surprise
the viewers with something unexpected
regardless of how illogical it was it
also didn't do much good in terms of
atmosphere in some cases it even
destroys the atmosphere built up just
for surprise reasons which is a very
interesting critique I wish the author
had actually given an example of what
one of those surprises would be and what
atmosphere had ruined I mean if I'm
being as generous as I can maybe a
surprise would be that the hunter exam
gets cut short which ruins the
atmosphere of the climax of The Ark but
I'm also not sure that atmosphere is
what this reviewer means to say the main
characters are also unexplained
overpowered sure there are a few
stronger but that alone doesn't justify
a little kid being physically stronger
than a well-trained grown-up man just
because he grew up in the woods which is
by the way contradicted later on I kind
of agree not that it gets contradicted
but gone is a super human for let's be
honest not very well explained reasons
super strength super speed some inherent
understanding of martial arts despite
not being taught by anyone but that is
exclusively the opening in every Arc
that follows gone feels almost painfully
underpowered a child who is constantly
and I mean constantly taking a beating
from adult men and no matter how much he
improves there is always someone to
smack him back down in the second Arc
the terror already begins motivations
from the character were completely
forgotten and not even mentioned in
order to have a little Conflict for the
goal of this Arc the reason for the
first Arc and what they have achieved
was completely pointless and even
contradictory as explained in later ARS
again I take issue with the word
contradictory because I don't know what
is contradicting what and again when you
say things like this in general you need
to cite an example because I
legitimately have no idea what the
author is talking about in any way shape
or form for example which character
motivation was forgotten and in favor of
what conflicts but also maybe this sort
of writing is a strategy to be so vague
that I can't possibly refute any of the
points being made because I don't know
what they are the following Arc shine
with not knowing what to call some
things what the so-called Mafia is a
bunch of unorganized idiots who
apparently have a lot of power they at
least have a lot of money which is
contradictory in every way and let me
question the whole world building of
this anime and we still don't know what
a hunter is and does again the word
contradictory I don't know what he's
referring to and how because I don't
know if powerful people having money is
contradictory to anything Hunter Hunter
set up before that in fact I feel like
it would be contradictory for powerful
mafas not to have money although I do
surprisingly agree that it does take a
long time to find out what a hunter
actually is my wife had that criticism
when watching the anime actually like
most of our main cast are now licensed
hunters and we as an audience still
don't know what that is at this point
anyway of course we find out later on
the writers have no idea of how money
Works which wouldn't be a problem if
they hadn't dedicated a whole Arc for
money getting purposes which is later on
also completely useless one might even
say contradictory I wouldn't but I'm
surprised he didn't and I think that
this is referring to the auction stuff
again I'm assuming in fact I'm making
the points for the reviewer who wrote
this review and yes admittedly a lot of
the auction stuff does go nowhere
however that doesn't mean it's useless
because what it does is reinforce the
unpredictability of the series you can
never accurately know what turn it's
going to take because some plot threads
follow through and some hit UNS
satisfying dead ends and I also think
it's fair enough to be annoyed by those
because that's not standard storytelling
practice you can't set something up and
not pay it off but at the same time this
person claims not to enjoy standard
shown and storytelling so whether you
like it or not this is something that
definitely separates hunter hunter from
being just another Shonen some of the
arcs are complete filler since they
either are pointless or have nothing to
do with the final goal the motivation of
the main protagonist there is even one
Arc where the protagonist is inside a
video game and literally the first thing
he hears is that being here is
completely pointless but he doesn't care
and goes on anyway which makes the whole
Arc pointless and questions the
existence of the buildup to it it's a
pretty funny way of putting it actually
I mean I completely disagree in fact I
think it's the exact opposite but I do
like out of context summaries as much of
a blue Ball's moment as it may have been
forgone in the end that message was all
part of Jing's test because he did
program Greed Island with a mechanic for
gone to complete the game and find him
the test was would gone still go through
with this even if he thought it wasn't
going to result in reaching Jin and he
did gone past the test he didn't pass
the second test though which was to see
Jing alone but this also establishes
Jing as an unreliable source you can
never take anything he says at face
value which is very non-standard for a
Shonen Series where all information no
matter who it's delivered by is intended
to be truth to inform the readers
meanwhile sometimes in Hunter Hunter
information will be blatantly wrong
tagashi will lie straight to your face
and it's up to us to interpret it as
much as it's up to the characters this
show becomes less endurable from Arc to
Arc with the mafia Arc being an
exception but still not good it's like
comparing a pile of with a pile of
which has a cherry on top of it you
know at least an exception was made for
yoru it's an acknowledgement that it was
a little tiny step up tiny Step Up is
one of the most memorable ARS in anime
history but I want to know know why
though because I think it's perfectly
fine to not like Hunter Hunter it's a
weird series it is not Universal but
this review is a lot of saying yeah
thing was bad but not adding it was bad
because of the following the thing that
really bothers me as well is the fact
that the show has no scale whatsoever
the abilities and strength of every
character are so completely random and
out of order it even shifts during the
whole anime making character who should
be strong considering their rank utterly
weak and character who should be weak
unnecessarily strong I'll say it again I
need examples this is too vague but but
to play Devil's Advocate if I had to
make the reviewer's argument for them
I'd say that characters like meni buhara
and satt look very weak in retrospect
considering their status as presented at
the beginning of the series but also I
actually agree with every character
being quote random and out of order
because that's how nen combat is
designed to function due to the
endlessly creative application of nen a
veteran tops scale nen user could fall
to an amateur with a favorable ability
match up that's what makes Hunter Hunter
exciting with the exception of a few
characters it cannot be scaled which
means that each new conflict presents
new tension and new surprises and I
guess if you wanted a more clear scale
than what you would go and do is read a
most standard Shonen where Whoever has
the most Keys Whoever has the most
chakras Whoever has the most rius just
wins so again this criticism is that
Hunter Hunter isn't a standard Shonen
whereas this review is all about saying
Hunter Hunter is a standard Shonen and I
will prove to you why the Chimera and
talk is the worst thing I have seen in a
long time in terms of writing and here
we go none of the so-called ant villains
look even remotely like an ant that's
that's that's kind of the point of the
ants the ants are the base and they
absorb the qualities of their food and
it's literally the entire ideological
exploration of the Ark what makes a
human human can you still be human as an
ant and are you still an ant even though
you physically and mentally departed
from anood also on the flip side does
being a human prevent you becoming an
instinctual animal like monster so
tagashi really needs to blur those lines
and make us question what is a human
what is an ant and he does that by not
making them all look like ants not to
mention how boring would the arc be if
every single Chimera ant just looks like
the Queen the writers wanted to make
this show dark and mature but only
showed how childish their writing is
again example what which which part of
the writing was childish but also notice
the reviewer says writers plural that
one simple s proving that they don't
know anything about manga production or
did any research on the production of
the series at all not that you should
have to to write a review but if you
going to make a claim like this then
yeah you do Hunter Hunter is written by
single author and while this might be a
pretty Petty point to dwell on I do
think it's very telling of the Swift
assumptions the reviewer makes in this
Arc hunter hunter really shows how
little time they spend with thinking
through the whole thing where villains
came from and what their motivation is
was never Hunter Hunter spends any time
in but in this case it makes absolutely
no sense that some ant people who just
came into existence are able to be as
strong as one of the strongest person in
the whole anime so again no scale
existed I think this is wild because the
motivation of the ants is almost
exclusively what this Arc focuses on the
ants start in this place of mindless
obedience and then gradually they all
develop their individual personalities
and conflict arises especially maram who
under goes an in-depth exploration of
what it means to be specifically the
king and is struggling with his ant
versus human ideologies so to say that
they have no motivation just tells me
that you didn't listen to the dialogue I
think it's fine to say that you maybe
didn't like their motivation that you
didn't care about the motivation but to
say that it simply wasn't there is just
blanketly false and in fact we spend so
much more time diving into those
characters and exploring motivations
than we do on fights which is very
non-standard Shon lots of introspective
examinations of characters like ealo
welin cheu leol and so on and so forth
there's so many and of course the
existence of the answer as a whole is
explained in the next Arc because not
every mystery needs to be solved
immediately and also not every unsolved
mystery is dissatisfying either and I
guess if you want those plain obvious
in- yourface explanations then you need
need to read a more standard sh not in
the Last Arc the tactics really shine oh
this is nice in terms of sucking sick
burn bro in the last 50 episodes there
is only one fight anyways so there is
not much to talk about that I mean that
that's a hyperbole but this is kind of
what I was saying we spend so much time
focusing on motivations and characters
that the fights are actually quite
sparse now if what you want is less
character examination and more punch
fighty action then I'll say it again
what you need is a more standard Shonen
which is the thing you don't like
however you you also don't like Hunter
Hunter for not doing the thing it is you
don't like do you like anything
characters of this show are not in any
terms special have you seen either
Naruto one piece bleach you know the
personality of the main character have
you seen Hunter Hunter I think this is a
fair opinion if you've only seen the
first few episodes maybe just the hunter
exam Arc gone does start out very
admittedly generically but to think that
someone has reached the Chimera ant Arc
and still thinks that his personality as
a carbon copy of Luffy is just
incompatible with my inbuilt logic and a
bunch of extra side character characters
and you got them all it's just the
typical teenager character who is strong
enough to change the world stuff this
one definitely needs an example because
here's a good question when does gone
ever change the world when does gone
ever change a country a city a town when
does gone change anything except for a
couple of rare individuals it's the
exact opposite of the typical stuff gon
is consistently a teenager who is so
weak that he struggles to change even a
single person let alone the world and
even ends up losing himself he really
does exist very much as the anti- Shon
protagonist he is a very wish-fulfilling
character and not that much of a role
model I agree completely I think that
gone is selfish really selfish he's
definitely not a role model and that is
what makes him compelling he's not a
role model he's a cautionary tail and if
you want a role model then we already
know what I'm going to say next but you
need a more standard shown art style is
simple and character design in the whole
show is the worst I have ever seen but
of course that's only my opinion I mean
art is subjective that's fair enough and
I know that words are difficult but I
just I I just want to know why so here's
a potentially H opinion I'm not a fan of
the attack on Titan art style especially
in the beginning I find it very rough
very sketchy and very syy like a lot of
the time I think the characters just
aren't distinguishable enough and
everything just evolves into this like
generic blob of isama character design
and I'm not saying it's bad I think that
rough style very much adds a nice layer
of texture to the atmosphere of the
attack on Titan World it just doesn't
appeal to me personally and I guess it
just would have been nice to know what
it is about the hunter hunter art style
which I think is very may be it may be
one of the most inoffensive art styles
in all of anime just very Schmick very
clean so I would love to know what it is
about that art style that just didn't
really jealy so overall this show is not
more than a Shonen and I might add the
worst written Shonen I have ever seen
but I am not into that genre so I only
saw a few of them this is just so
incompatible with everything the
reviewer has said he has spent this
entire review insisting that Hunter
Hunter is a standard Shonen but then
chastising it for not doing what a
standard Shonen should do the main
character isn't a role model some of the
plot threads don't pay off there's not
enough fights not enough action too much
character introspection and yet not
enough motivations if you are a person
who likes more matury stuff and think
there is something behind this anime
otherwise it wouldn't be so popular
don't fall for the Trap and stay away
from it in the end you will just regret
it meanwhile the aggregate rating on my
anime list for Hunter Hunter remains at
9.04 out of 10 and I guess the main
takeaway I have from this review is that
Hunter Hunter is bad it's bad for many
reasons none of which I can name if you
have a reason let me know in the
comments